نعم ، التصعيد في أوكرانيا حسنًا ،
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، لا توجد قوات روسية
في أوكرانيا ، لا توجد قوات روسية
في دونباس
أه هناك قوات
روسية على الأراضي الروسية على الأراضي الروسية
المجاورة للحدود الأوكرانية ،
إنه أمر مفهوم تمامًا
كما تعلمون يقول المراقبون الدوليون
أن هناك  هل الجنود الروس لا
يرتدون الزي الرسمي
الروسي ولكن هناك جنود روس في دونباس ،
هناك الآن قوات روسية غبية
أنا أه
أنا المتحدث باسم الكرملين ويمكنني
أن أخبرك رسميًا أنه لا
توجد قوات روسية أو لا يوجد على دونباس
وعلى الأراضي الأوكرانية
ولكن هناك قوات روسية على
أراضي الاتحاد الروسي
بجوار الحدود الأوكرانية ونجد من
الضروري إبقاء تلك القوات هناك
في
مواجهة الوضع المتوتر
للغاية والبيئة غير الودية
التي خلقتها أه تدريبات مختلفة لطائرة الناتو
أه.  مقاتلو الناتو طائرات التجسس
أه
البنية التحتية العسكرية لحلف الناتو تتحرك
نحو
حدودنا أو نحوها علينا الرد
علينا أن نأخذ  التدابير الاحترازية
لهذا السبب لدينا رجالنا العسكريون في
أراضينا هناك هل لديك
نوع من الجدول الزمني الذي تكون
فيه عند هذه النقطة أه ستقول بعد ذلك إن
المفاوضات قد فشلت وهل
أنت مستعد بعد ذلك للقيام بعمل عسكري
بشكل جيد.  إعادة الحديث عن
عمل عسكري
أه
هذا عليك أن تفهم أنه
لا أحد يهدد أحداً
بعمل عسكري
هذا سيكون مجرد جنون لفعل ذلك
لكننا سنكون مستعدين لمحاولة
الرد